[موسيقى]
انه الحجاب فرض على المراه دون الرجل
اصوات دعت الى ارتدائه واخرى تح على خلعه
جدل في المجتمعات العربيه امتد الى الدول
الاوروبيه هنا في فرنسا بعضهم يعتبر
الحجاب استعباده للمراه فيدعو الى منعه
واخرون يدخلونه خانه الحريه الشخصيه
فيدافع عنه ونحن نسال في القرن ال 21
لماذا نغطي المراه وهل يتماشى الحجاب مع
علمانيه الدوله ما راي المواطن الفرنسي
بذلك في فلك الممنوع
[موسيقى]
لنشاهد لا لا انا اللي بغ يدير الحجاب
يعيش في بلاده ويسوي الدين دياله في
بلادنا انا دايره البوني
فيرج الامر يعود لهن على المحجبات وحدهن
خوض معركه التحرر ولا د لنا النساء
الغربيات ليس علينا ان نقول لهن ان كان
الحجاب رمزا للخضوع ام لا اذا لا يصدمك
الحجاب
لا انا ضد ارتداء الحجاب صحيح اننا في بلد
الحريات ولكن لا لزوم للظهور بهذا الشكل
بالنسبه لي للجميع الحق في ارتداء ما
يشاء البعض يريد ان يكون على الموضه ويلون
شعره بالاخضر والاصفر البعض يريد ارتداء
الحجاب او وضع الكبه او الصليب هذا امر
شخصي
وعلينا جميعا ان نتعايش دون احكام
مسبقه البعض يستقصد استفزازنا افهموا ان
تقوم السيدات المسنات بارتداء الحجاب فهذا
في تقاليده لكن الشابات المقيمات في فرنسا
عليهن التكيف مع ثقافه البلد الذي يقب فيه
فقط ارتداء الحجاب لا
يزعجني انا لا اوافق في بلادهن لهن الحق
بذلك ولكننا هنا في دوله ديمقراطيه
هنا
فرن براي الحجاب يتماشى مع العلمانيه بل
اكثر هو يتطابق مع العلمانيه التي تضمن
حريه اللباس هذا حق من الحقوق في فرنسا
الاستثناء الوحيد قانونيا هو في حالات
التبشير او الدعوه او في مكان
العمل لا افهم لما على النساء ان يضعن
الحجاب ورا ذلك فرض واضح وهذا ما
يزعجني لهن حريه ارتداء الحجاب ولا احد
يمكنه ان يمنعه
لكل شخص ديانته فرنسا بلد الحريات وشعارها
حريه مساواه واخاء ارتداء الحجاب لا يتلا
بعض الاماكن اما في الشارع فالامر لا
يزعجني هذا عار نستقبلهم في فرنسا
ويستفزونهم اعتقد اننا نحن الفرنسيات لو
قررنا التنزه بالتنوره القصيره فان هذا
الامر لن يعجب المتدينين
يقولون اننا عنصريون كلا هم
يستفزنا الطريقه التي نناقش فيها الحجاب
مؤخرا تصدمني كثيرا لانها تحرض الناس على
بعضهم البعض دون ان يطرح السؤال الاساسي
وهو لماذا لماذا تحتاج شريحه شابه من
الجيل الجديد لمعرفه ثقافه اهلها واجداد
يجب ان نطرح هذا النوع من الاسئله عوضا عن
تصنيف الاشخص وفق اصولهم وهو امر يدمر
العيش المشترك ويستغل الخوف من الاخر
واساليب بغيضه كهذه في المرح
الحاليه اسماء جنفي ناشطه نسويه اختصاصيه
علم نفس والمديره السابقه لجمعيه نت نيسيز
هنا في باريس اسماء انت من الداعين الى
منع الحجاب في فرنسا لماذا منع الحجاب
ومنع كل الرموز الدينيه لاننا نعيش في بلد
علماني نحن في فرنسا دوله اور اوروبا كذلك
لها تاريخ لها عادات وتقاليد وبالنسبه لي
الحجاب ليس حريه للمراه الحجاب بالنسبه لي
هو رمز العنف رمز
رمز هيمنه الرجال على النساء بالنسبه لي
الحجاب يبرر المراه الحجاب وعندما اقول
هذا اتذكر كاتيا بن جانا الجزائريه في
عمرها 18 سنه قتلت لانها رفضت لبس الحجاب
اتكلم واتذكر كل النساء السعوديات
والافغاني وكل الذين لا يريدون لبس الحجاب
اذا اسماء انت تعتبرين انها انه يفرض بشكل
قمعي على السيدات ا طيب معنا هنا في
الاستديو سميه الطبوبي محاميه هنا في
باريس تضحكين سميه انت مواطنه فرنسيه
تعيشين في دوله علمانيه ما رايك يعني
اليوم هل تعتبرين ان حجابك يتماشى مع
العلمانيه حجابي لا اقول انه يتماشى مع
العلمانيه ولكن اقول ان الحجاب ليس له
اتصال وليس له دام مع العلمانيه كيف يعني
ان الحجاب هو فرض اسلامي بالنسبه لي كل
مراه لها الحق ان تتحجب ام ليس مفروضه على
المراه كماقال انا لم يفرض احد
و مهنه م ولكن هذا نسمعه غالبا يا سم ان
لم يفرض احد نرجع
الاول بادئ ذ يجب علينا ان نرجع الى مصطلح
العلمانيه ما معنى العلمانيه
التي تساق هنا وهناك العلمانيه ما هي
لنرجع الى العلمانيه العلمانيه هي قانون
اتخذ لمكافحه الكنيسه في عهد كانت فيه
الكنيسه تطغى على الدوله 1905 ماذا فيه
القانون فيه القانون
شيئان الدوله علمانيه بمعنى ان فصل الدوله
الفرنسيه الفصل فصل ما معنى هذا يعني
الدوله لا تعترف باي دين ا الدوله ليس لها
دين الدوله ليس لها دين عظيم والثانيه
الدوله لا تؤجر الدين طيب الفينوس طيب هذه
هي العلمانيه ما معنى يعني المانيه اصلا
يعني ولكن اذا فكرنا قليلا العلمانيه لا
يعني لا تتماشى مع الين اسلامي فعل
ن
العلمانيه لا ن نحن نقلب الموازين اليوم
نقول هل ان الحجاب في سيدام مع العلمانيه
الموضوع هو العلمانيه هل يمكن للعلمانيه
ان ان تحتضن الحجاب
نعم ان اقول ان الاسلام يحتضن العلمانيه
شيء
اخر يعني انت تفصلين الحجاب عن الاسلام
وعن العلمانيه تع العلمانيه تحتضن الحجاب
يمكن لها ان تفعل ذلك طيب
العلمانيه تحفظ كل الديانات العلمانيه لو
لم تكن فرنسا علمانيه لا انا ولا انت
سيدتي نستطيع ان نعيش في فرنسا ولماذا انت
تعيشين بدون حجاب وانا لا اعيش بالحجاب لا
هذا الشيء الذي يتغير هو فقط لان
للعلمانيه لها قوانين والقوانين الجمهوريه
ما هي القوانين القوانين هي يجب نحترم
القوانين الجمهوريه هي القوانين القوانين
الديمقراطيه القوانين ممنوع
الدخول بالرموز الدينيه الى المدارس الى
الحضانات ال لا لكن هذ استثناءات نحن لا
يعني انت موافقين على الاستثناءات انت
يعني تعتبرين انه من يعني انت تتماشي مع
عدم الدخول بالحجاب الى الاماكن الرسميه
الادارات الرسميه الى المدارس الى
الحضانات انت توافقين انا لا اوافق لا
توافقين اق لكن لا اوافق يعني هذا اي
قانون لنا ان نكون حتى في البرلمان هناك
من يصوت مع القانون وهناك من يصو ضد
القانون انا لا اخجل ان اقول اليوم اني لا
اوافق على القانون الذي منع الحجاب في
المدارس انا لا اوافق لان الغايه من من من
منع الحجاب لان الغايه من منع الحجاب في
المدارس غايه سياسيه بحته اريد
بها
اقصاء المسلمين ولكن لماذا لا تنظرين الى
انه ربما هذا القانون يريد ان يساوي كل
الناس يعني ان نظهر كلنا بنفس الشكل كلنا
نع ان نمارس ديننا في منزلنا في اماكن
خاصه وليس في
ال الدين الدوله تحفظ الدين في كل مكان
الدوله تحفظ الدين في كل مكان وان اذكرك
بان المانيا دوله علمانيه بامتياز المانيا
دوله ديمقراطيه بامتياز دوله علمانيه ليست
دوله دينيه ولكن في المانيا تع ان
المواطنين الالمان يدفعون ضرائب للكنيسه
نعم لا لكن لان الديمقراطيه شي
عنن الاخت الفاضله تخلط الامور العلمانيه
نما تخل تخلط الامور هناك خلط بين
الديمقراطيه وبين العلمانيه وبين ثم هناك
اوجه كثيره طيب للسياسه الان الديمقراطيه
ما هي الديمقراطيه هي حكم الشعب نفسه
بنفسه يعني من يصنع طيب يعني القانون
ديمقراطيا اليوم الشعب اختار ان يمنع الحج
ما دخل الديني في الديمقراطيه ما دخل حريه
الدينيه في
الديمقراطيه الحب
س لا يوجد اعطيني فصل في الدستور الفرس
الديمقراطيه نستمع للاغلبيه وليس للاقليه
انتم اقليه هل يجب على الاقليه ان ترفد
نفسها على الاغلبيه هذا ليست
ديمقراطيه
طيب نعود نعود الى هذا النقاش بس دعونا
فقط دعونا لنبقى في في الحجاب قبل ان
نناقش الديمقراطيه سنبقى ايضا في فرنسا
استطلعنا اراء نساء محجبات مقيمات هنا
ماذا يعني ان تكوني محجبه في فرنسا وهل
تعتبرين ان النظره للمحجبات تغيرت وان
حجابك يعيق اندماجك في المجتمع الفرنسي
لنشاهد
حس حاجه
ثقيله ح صعيب الحال بزاف انا في
فرنسا
بكري بزف الحوايج انا بنتي قاع خرجت من
على حجاب خلات
[موسيقى]
المغرب نحس روحي مليحه
والله في فرنسا تو حن المحجبات نحس روحنا
غرباء
سبب 93
[موسيقى]
جب va mais o je j'ai rendez-vous
paris franchement je me s totalement
trs
diff il yit un jour o j'avais un
rendez-vous avec
orl
rendezvous voil pour mes oreilles en
fait j' trs
agress qu'est-ce que vous faites la
france est pour les catholiques c'est
pas pour les
[موسيقى]
musulmans alg fr nation
et de pays
franceg dans je me s trs bien mais aprs
c'est parfois les gens le regard des
gens malheureusement comme je vous ai
dit tout l'heure on est tellement
catalog les gens
parfois
entc
[موسيقى]
pas tout س انا
ودي دي
مايش يخدم واحد يخدم تدي
[موسيقى]
الحجابي اسماء جنفي اليوم الدعوه الى منع
الحجاب في فرنسا الا تعني في المقابل
تهميش شريحه كبيره من السيدات المسلمات
مواطنات فرنسيات مسلمات لا اعتقد لان انا
بالنسبه لي الحجاب ليس فرض على المسلمه
نستطيع ان نكون مسلمه ونطبق الاسلام في
فرنسا ونعيش ديننا في فرنسا بدون هذا
الرمز الذي هو بالنسبه لي ليس ض ليس رمز
للمسلمه هل توافقين انا لا
اوافق ان يكون
الحجاب خيار وليس فرض على المسلمه هذا امر
ديني شرعي بت فيه ولو ان هو فرض وليس خيار
بالنسبه هو فرض لكن للمراه ان تختار
ان هناك خلاف يعني على مساله الفرض
ولكن
الاماميه انت تعتبرين اليوم ان النظره
للمحجبه تغيرت في فرنسا النظره المحجبه
تغيرت فعلا في فرنسا منذ ان جاء سكوزي
لحكم من 2004 الخطاب السياسي نعم خطاب
سياسي بحث لم يكن انا متح انا عشت في
فرنسا فترتين فتره غير متحجبه وفتره
متحجبه الاسلام العنصري انا اعتقد ان فتره
متحجبه وفتره غير متحجبه فتره كنت في
الجامعه ك يعني انت تلقي باللوم فقط لنوضح
تلقينا باللوم على السياسه الفرنسيه
الداخليه وليس على تصاعد الحركات السياسيه
الاسلاميه المتشدده هناك تصاعد حركات
سياسيه نعم لكن كان هناك توظيف سياسي
داخلي فرنسي هناك سياسه ارعاب استمع الى
اسماء لان اسماء ستغادر ستغادر هنا برايك
لماذا تغيرت النظره للمحجبات في فرنسا لان
السياق اليوم هو سياق الارهاب الخوف
الفرنسيين يخافون يخوفون من من ما يحصل
اليوم وخاصه انا اعتقد ان ليست يمكن تكون
سياسه سكوزي انا لن ادافع على سياسه سكوزي
ولكن وجود المسلمين السياسيين هي الي غيرت
اسلام السياسي الاسلام السياسي هي الي
غيرت نظره الفرنسيين بالنسبه للحجاب ط
بسرعه لكما هل محجبه هي من تقصي نفسها
بسبب غطاء الراس ام ان المجتمع هو من
يقصيه برايك ان المجتمع لا يقصي المحجبه
وهناك خيار سياسي المجتمع استمعنا الى
الشارع الفرنسي الشارع الفرنسي الشارع
الفرنسي وانا اعيش في الشارع الفرنسي اكثر
الناس نعم ولكن الاكثر الناس متفهمين
للحجاب انا اعيش انا محاميه انا اذهب
لمحاكم اتعامل مع الحرفاء اتعامل مع الناس
مع الادارات هناك اكثر من 80% من المجتمع
متسامح مع الحجاب ولا يرفض الحجاب انا
اعتقد تقصي نفسها ام يقصيه المجتمع المح
الاول هي المراه هي التي تقصي على نفسها
لانها ترتدي الرمز الرمز الذي يفرقها مع
المجتمع يفرقها مع الرجال
خاصه اجرينا استطلاعا للراي على تويتر
طرحنا سؤالا هل ارتداء الحجاب فريضه دينيه
ام اختيار شخصي 86% قالوا انه فريضه دينيه
مقابل 14% اعتبروا الحجاب اختيارا شخصيا
وذلك من اصل اكثر من 2000 شخص شملهم
الاستطلاع وغالبيتهم يقيمون في الدول
العربيه بعد الفاصل نعرفكم على شريف
الشوباشي كاتب وصحفي مصري دعا نساء مصر
الى خلع الحجاب وقال ان الحجاب جزء من
الارهاب الديني وايضا نعرفكم على سيده
عربيه قررت خلع الحجاب بعد في فلك الممنوع
نعود بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل